barnier halloween c'est soit aujourd'hui
soit dans très peu de jours je ne sais
pas quand cette vidéo sera mise en ligne
c'est bon mais ce que je sais c'est que
pour halloween vous et je voulais un
thread horreur aujourd'hui trois
histoires une courte une moyenne et
longue
trois mécaniques différentes et trois
trucs qui font très peur voilà dix
minutes je vous dise
la première histoire c'est celle de
camille cas mais il vient de divorcer ça
arrive
et le truc le plus important pour elle
en revanche vu qu'elle avait eu des
enfants c'était d'avoir la garde de son
fils de 4 ans elle expliqué après avoir
quasiment tout perdu suite à son divorce
vous savez la répartition des biens etc
elle a pris un nouveau départ avec son
fils en emménageant dans une toute
nouvelle maison avec juste quelques
affaires et quelques meubles mais
vraiment pas grand chose bref un vrai
nouveau départ elle explique que ça lui
arrive est la première nuit qu'elle a
passées dans cette maison avec son fils
aucun répit la pauvre camille truc assez
classique son fils se réveille en pleine
nuit ce mât pleurer probablement un
cauchemar ou autre chose il l'appelle
j'aime pas ça moi j'aime pas déjà ce
truc d'enfants qui pleure et qui appelle
les parents c'est très fréquent mais moi
je faisais tout temps quand j'étais
petit mes chaînes par tu te débrouilles
fiston voilà ce que je dirais mans et
donc camille se lève et va dans la
chambre de son fils pour le rassurer
elle se met à son chevet et à lui
demande qu'est ce qui se passe et son
fils eut fait le coup classique du il y
à un monstre dans le placard ça s'est vu
et revu dans le sens où il ya beaucoup
d'enfants qui ont déjà dit cette phrase
et qui ont fait des cauchemars en
rapport avec le placard cas où l'armoire
dans leurs champs
camille explique que vu les
circonstances récente c'est pas étonnant
que son fils fasse des cauchemars et qui
disent des trucs comme ça là il vient
d'emménager dans une nouvelle maison
pour la première fois de sa vie et elle
est à peine meublé donc bref toutes ces
circonstances font que oui c'est plutôt
normal qu'ils seraient bien en pleine
nuit et qui pleure et qui croient qu'ils
imposent en plein coeur bref camille
s'apprête à aller vers le placard et
avant de se lever avant même de regarder
paca elle réalise qu'il ya un truc qui
est vraiment pas normal
elle tourne malgré tout la tête vers le
placard est là elle explique qu'elle se
retient de céder à la panique et à la
peur parce qu'il ya son fils qui est à
côté d'elle et qu'elle veut pas lui
transmettre son stress et sa peur c'est
ce fameux truc hein quand tes parents tu
es prêt à tout pour protéger ton enfant
y compris de la réalité de la gravité de
la situation née à ce moment précis
camille comprend que elle et son fils
doivent très vite quitté la pièce et
même quitté la maison pendant qu'elle
réfléchit à tout ça elle entend des
arènes les portes du placard qui s'ouvre
elle explique alors qu'ils aient un
petit silence de quelques
à l'issue duquel elle récupère son fils
elle récupère les clés de la voiture et
il fonce tous les deux dans la voiture
pour se barrer de la maison toujours
dans l'optique de protéger son fils de
la gravité de la situation elle explique
qu'elle n'arrive pas à dormir et qu'elle
trouve que c'est cool s'ils vont manger
une glace ensemble
bref c'est bien beau tout ça mais il y
avait quoi dans black hat camille
explique qu'en fait elles étaient déjà
venus quelquefois auparavant dans la
maison et que comme elle l'a dit elle
avait à peine quelques meubles et à
faire et que parmi ces meubles
il n'y avait pas de plat car il n'y
avait pas de placards dans la chambre de
son fils c'est donc pour ça que quand
son fils a parlé d'un placard et que au
regard dans la wii pointé du doigt elle
a vu qu'il y avait vraiment un placard
elle s'est tout de suite mise à
comprendre qu'il fallait partir c'est
horrible qui a mis ce placard là quand
il la mit pourquoi il l'a mis à iavoloha
domaine mais je ne veux pas que ce soit
chez moi qu'ils fassent ça clairement si
vous emménagez fait donc à face qui est
par meublant plus entre le moment où
vous avez mis les meubles et cetera chez
vous et le moment où vous y dormait pour
la voir on n'est jamais à l'abri d'un
mec qui vient installer son petit
placard pour préparer quelque chose
un nom mais toi tout va bien dans cette
deuxième histoire qui est horrible et
qui est déjà arrivé à pas mal de
personnes en réalité dans la vie alors
pas de cette manière là exact mais cette
mécanique lie déjà arrivé plusieurs fois
des gens et c'est horrible je m'explique
margot la fille à qui est arrivé cette
histoire rencontre greg en vacances et
c'est le coup de fouet et tombe très
vite très fort amoureux et ils se
marient deux mois plus tard avant même
d'avoir chacun rencontré la famille de
l'autre margot expliqué lin taf qui lui
prend énormément de temps qu'elle a que
très très peu de vacances et que donc
ils ont dû attendre à peu près six mois
avant que lé enfin une semaine de
vacances et qu'elle puisse donc
rencontré la famille de greg le jour j
c'est un peu un événement ça y est la
famille de greg rencontre enfin sa
fiancée et tout le monde a l'air très
content et ravi sauf la mère de greg
elle est froide elle est distante elle
adresse même pas un seul mot à margaux
bizarre greg et margot décide de faire
une petite sortie au parc national situé
juste à côté de la maison des parents du
legs betsy la mère de greg préparent le
déjeuner et quelques heures plus tard
quand il s'apprête à aller au parc
margot à des vagues de nos épaules et
elle passe l'après-midi au-dessus des
chiottes
bon ça arrive d'avoir des nausées dette
mal le temps d'une après mme margot elle
s'alarme pas trop elle pense juste
qu'elle a chopé un petit virus et du
coup ils vont pas au parc
bref le temps passé quelques mois plus
tard margot et grecs décident de
retourner chez les parents grecs parce
qu'il est quand même passé un bon moment
malgré ses nausées là l'après-midi et de
nouveaux betsy est froide et distante
exactement comme la première fois avec
margot bien entendu greg il justifie
auprès de opprime margot et lui explique
qu'il lui dit voilà ma mère elle est
comme ça elle va mettre pas mal de temps
avant de s'apprécier elle t'a vu qu'une
seule fois pour le moment donc
voilà c'est normal margot elle est un
peu deg c'est toujours cool quand ça se
passe bien avec les beaux-parents vous
savez mais bon elle se dit bon asie sert
à mieux avec le temps je fais confiance
à gré la veille de leur départ greg
propose qu'ils aillent louer des jet
skis pour aller en enfer sur le lac de
la ville voisine
même scénario que leur premier séjour
chez le beau parent betty prépare le
repas qu'ils mangent et margot passe la
fremm à vomir la sortie est donc annulée
et à partir de ce moment margot se met à
avoir des doutes sur betsy ça fait deux
fois qu'elle tombe extrêmement malade et
les deux fois c'est quand elle était en
séjour chez la famille de greg et quand
betty avait préparé le repas repas que
tout le monde à manger et à l'issue
duquel uniquement margot fini dans la
salle de bain à vomir tout la preuve au
dessus de l'évier
margot elle a donc des médias doute et
c'est lors de leur troisième visite que
ses doutes se confirme et qui se passe
exactement la même chose le déjeuner
avant qu'il fasse la sortie est préparé
par la mère de greg betsy et margot fini
une nouvelle fois au dessus de l'évier
dans la salle de bains a déjà plus de
doute betsy lent poison
elle en parle donc à greg qui le prend
extrêmement mal et qui lui dit qu'elle
est folle et que ça n'a aucun sens il
lui explique que ça se trouve elle est
tout simplement allergique à un
ingrédient que sa mère utilise dans sa
cuisine et ses possibles en vrai mais
bon trois fois ils vont là bas trois
fois le vomi à d'autres margot reste sûr
que betsy l'empoisonnent et
effectivement elle a de quoi penser ça
donc elle va donc préparer un petit plan
pour que lors de ses prochaines visites
elle est la preuve que ben est si lent
poison
lors de sa quatrième visite chez les
parents de greg elle décide d'emmener sa
propre casseroles et elle de faire à
manger pour tout le monde le séjour se
finit une fois de plus par margot qui
vomit et en fait elle réalise qu'elle a
laissé son verre de vin sans
surveillance à de multiples reprises et
donc elle suppose que betsy amis du
poison dans son verre cette fois et pas
dans le plat margot pète un câble et
elle dit à greg bon là c'est trop mec
moi je viens plus jamais elle explique
que c'était la première grosse
embrouille de leur couple et que ça lui
a fondu le coeur mais que c'était trop
point les mois passent et margot y
décide de partir en week-end dans un
petit chalet et il se trouve qu'en s'y
rendant sur le chemin il passe devant la
maison de betsy la mère de greg et il
décide donc de s'arrêter pour leur dire
un petit bonjour comme beaucoup de mois
sont passés sans qu'elle ait vu la
famille de greg margot allait elle est
ok pour passer le voir elle un peu moins
valeur qu'avant puisque ça fait un
moment qu'elle n'a pas fini la prem tout
simplement au dessus d'un lavabo mais
elle refuse de boire ou de manger quoi
que ce soit qui vient de la maison des
parents de greg
donc il faut un petit détour pour
acheter des pizzas et de l'eau et après
ils s'y rendent ils se mettent donc tous
à table chacun prend une part de pizza
est là il ya un cousin de greg qui
arrive est comme ça faisait un moment
que personne n'avait vu
monde se tourne vers lui et les
assiettes sont donc laissés sans
surveillance
margot ça elle réalise quelques minutes
plus tard et elle se doute donc que
betsy en a profité pour mettre du poison
sur sa part de pizza l échange donc son
assiette avec celle de greg et bingo
cette fois c'est pas margot qui filmait
après mottu du lavabo
mais c'est greg est là enfin la preuve
ultime que betsy l'empoisonnent le blème
c'est que greg il a pas été malade une
aprem il a été malade trois jours une
fois rétabli margot décide de lui dire
ce qu'elle a fait elle expliqué l'avais
jamais vu comme ça et sous la colère il
l'a même poussé contre un mur et il l'a
pris par le bras il a balancé sur le
canapé bref un vrai fils de [ __ ]
heureusement margot elle réussit à
prendre les clés de sa voiture et elle
se casse avant que greg pète encore plus
5 1 margot fonds se réfugier chez sa
meilleure pote qui heureusement
n'habitez pas très loin de chez elles
sur le chemin elle explique qu'elle
reçoit une quarantaine d'appels de greg
auquel elle ne répond pas et une fois
arrivés chez son ami a décidé d'éteindre
son téléphone parce que greg larsen au
bout de deux jours elle décide quand
même de rallumer son téléphone
et là surprise entre les dizaines de
messages vocaux que greg a laissé elle a
un message non pas de greg mais de la
police et dans ce message elle apprendre
que greg a fini au commissaire hier
parce que betsy la mère de greg a appelé
la police en voyant greg rôder autour de
chez elle avec un couteau à la main
qu'est ce que c'est que ce bordel margot
prend donc contact avec betsy et betsy
arrête d'être froide et distante et elle
explique à margaux l'histoire et
l'histoire c'est qu'avant margot greg
était marié à une autre femme qui est
décédée aux suites d'un accident mortel
de randonnée greg gagner beaucoup
d'argent grâce à l'assurance vie de son
ex compagne décédée est en fait ben
sylla maire de greg l'a toujours
soupçonné d'avoir tué son ancienne femme
donc en fait ben si elle avait juste
peur de laisser margot seule avec son
fils elle a donc fait en sorte qu'à
chaque fois qu'ils aient une sortie de
prévue ensemble tous les deux margotton
malades et du coup la sortie soit
annulée margot explique que oui c'était
une méthode de merde mais que d'un autre
côté ben et si c'était la seule qu'ils
suspectaient son fils d'avoir fait ça et
que du coup elle pouvait en parler à
personne et encore moins la nouvelle
femme de greg depuis sa margot du coup
elle a même retrouvé chez eux des
papiers d'assurance vie qu'il a
contractée en son nom et qui montrent
donc qu'il comptait peut-être faire
pareil avec elle margot n'a pas porté
plainte contre betty parce qu'elle a
compris la situation et depuis du coup
les années sont passées et elles sont
restées en contact et margot mange même
des fois chez betty et elle explique
ironiquement qu'elle adore sa cuisine
quand elle n'est pas empoisonnée
voilà creepy et ça nous amène à notre
dernière histoire alors celle là la
mécanique frère je la déteste
laissez-moi donc vous raconter
l'histoire de alexandre alexandre il a
entendu parler d'un truc qui s'appelle
les flux webcams en direct c'est un truc
existe vraiment dans la vie je sais pas
si vous saviez mais il ya des webcams un
peu partout
soit c'est des gens qui les matches est
volontairement soit c'est des webcams
dehors souvent la mairie les installe
etc bref alexandre il développe une
passion pour ce délire de webcams en
direct
il regarde tous les top 10 de trucs
creepy qui se sont passées sur le web
cam en direct et il tombe sur une
histoire très connu qui s'appelle
chichan alors je vais pas vous raconter
aujourd'hui ce que c'est mais en gros
c'était à des webcams en direct qui
était chez une fille je crois coréenne
est elle restée immobile parfois pendant
vingt heures de suite il y avait des
trucs écrits sur des pancartes
et c'était médias creepy une histoire
une légende d'internet parmi les milieux
qu'il y en a une qui s'appelle type
shahab alexandre précise quand même
qu'il n'est pas particulièrement obsédé
par les trucs creepy mais lui ce qu'il
cherche c'est plus le web call back
comme je vous ai dit qu'il filme le nid
d'oiseau ou via des webcams aussi qui
sont placés en islande et sur lesquels
tu peux voir un peu les aurores boréales
donc faut aller sur le flux au bon
moment pour voir en direct l'aurore
boréale donc ça devient vraiment une
habitude ce truc de regarder des flux
web cam pour lui sauf que plus le temps
passe et moins il est captivé par les
webcams sur lesquels il vient
fréquemment iv ce fameux truc où tu fais
quelque chose depuis des jours des
semaines ou des mois et du coup bah sa
place est envie de passer à autre chose
dont qui se dirige sur des sites de flux
webcam en direct un peu plus dark et
découvre donc un site qui regroupe des
flux web cam bizarre qui sortent du
commun et alex est attiré par un flux
qui s'appelle 3 18 aces oblivion parce
que sur la miniature on aperçoit du coup
un morceau de maisons et sur le côté une
peinture et il se trouve qu alex
reconnaît cette peinture ce tableau
puisque c'est le cirque il réalise donc
en fait ce qu'ils voient sur ce flux du
web câble c'est sa chambre mais au
moment où il est en train de chéquiers
des flux il est dans sa cuisine sur son
ordinateur portable et du coup il a un
petit bug esi mais attends c'est bizarre
parce que la seule webcam du coup elle
est là avec moi dans mon pc portable
c'est quoi ce bordel pourquoi je vois ma
chambre sur un flux vidéo bref il
reprend ses esprits se concentre un peu
et il essaie de comprendre où est la
webcam dans sa chambre et d'après
l'angle de vue il suppose qu'elle se
trouve sur le côté gauche de son lit il
décide donc de se lever pour aller dans
sa chambre et pour voir s'il ya vraiment
une webcam dans sa chambre ou s'il se
fait des idées sauf que moment où il se
lève le live devient noir et il ya une
nouvelle image qui apparaît et cette
nouvelle image alexandre la reconnais
puisque c'est son salon comme pour sa
chambre il essaie de comprendre langue
de la webcam pour essayer de voir où
elle est dans son salon et il a à peine
le temps de comprendre où elle se trouve
que pareille l'écran devient noir et ça
passe à une autre pièce à ça
alex se voit sur le live assis dans sa
cuisine sur son ordinateur portable en
train de regarder
justement des lives webcam une nouvelle
fois il essaie de comprendre ou la
webcam et par rapport à l'angle de vue
il regarde dans la direction où elle est
censée être mais il voit pas de webcam
du coup il se met à checker l'heure du
live et ça correspond vraiment à l'heure
et la minute et la date du jour qui est
comprend donc c'est bien vrai live est
pas une blague
il ya deux personnes connectées aux
flûtes dont une qui met un commentaire
on est repéré supprimés ok alex est
tétanisé dans son pays at il dit mais
pourquoi est-ce que c'est réel c'est
quoi ce bordel
et comme souvent dans toutes ces
histoires horribles le seul réflexe qui
lassés de fermer son ordinateur et de se
casser loin il se rend chez un pote
auquel il explique tout ce qui vient de
se passer est son pote lui dis bah mec
juste appelle la police en fait tu leur
envoie le lien du live et tu leur donnes
l'adresse de ta maison et puis ils vont
faire ce qu'il faut alexandre appelle
donc la police il leur explique ce qui
vient de se passer il leur donne son
adresse il leur donne le lien du flux
vidéo et la police lui donne rendez vous
chez lui le lendemain à 10h du mat avec
un technicien qui lui sera chargé de
désinstaller les webcams au fur et à
mesure qu'il les trouve ils demandent
aussi alexandre de ramener tous ces
appareils électroniques pour les
vérifier et checker s'ils sont pas
traquer ou ce genre de conneries et il
se rend chez lui le lendemain matin à 10
heures comme prévu et il ya la police et
un technicien qui sont là il rentre dans
la maison ensemble pour essayer de
trouver toutes les webcams pendant que
la police inspecte toutes les pièces lui
et techniciens se rendre dans sa chambre
chambre dans laquelle souvenez vous il
ya le fameux tableau qui l'a attirée sur
ce flux live
sauf que le technicien trouve rien il
n'y a pas de webcam dans la chambre
d'alex et malheureusement même chose
pour la caméra dans le salon et même
chose pour la caméra dans la cuisine
toutes les caméras ont disparu donc le
technicien et la police part parce
qu'ils peuvent plus rien faire pour alex
sauf que alex sait ce qu'il a vu ici
qu'il y avait des caméras chez lui il
s'est qu'il était en direct sur internet
à son insu sauf que personne ne le
croira jamais parce qu'il n'y a plus
aucune preuve de cela et fini son
histoire en disant que depuis il est
vigilant et qui conseille aux gens de
faire la même chose parce qu'ils sont
peut-être observé à leur insu au moment
où il écrit son histoire
et ben voilà on est bien on va tous
mettre quoi ce soir chez nous un scotch
sur la webcam up et voilà c'est la fin
l'histoire d'élections d'été troisième
histoire et cette vidéo c'est trop bas
dont sans même tomber dans le délire de
gens qui installent des caméras chez toi
à ton insu juste les caméras qui sont
déjà chez toi les tiennes d'un webcam de
son ordinateur la caméra ton téléphone
moi c'est vraiment un truc j'ai trop
peur qu'on m'observe à mon insu ou qu'on
m'écoute à mon insu ça fait troupes et
tu vois que des mecs mark zuckerberg ou
gates met des [ __ ] de scotch sur la
webcam de leur ordi mais tu as envie de
faire pareil et tu te dis qu'à une
petite chance pour compte observe quand
même bref on parler de trucs horribles
mais bientôt c'est halloween alors
amusez vous bien qui fait bien que ce
soit seul chez vous ou en soirée avec
des potes jouer le jeu du déguisement
c'est toujours cool on se retrouve
bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo pour
des trucs un peu moins creepy mais
j'aime pas ce truc là ça fait pas des
aléas bientôt à tujac menace
on y vient
[Musique]